c
okay welcome to this live stream we are
talking about calculus and algebra
functionality
for the upcoming version of language and
this is the first time seeing of this
i don't know roger can you give me a
sense of how big this thing is
yeah so let me give you a backdrop to
this so in in the early days
of special functions we were sort of
happy with having numerical evaluation
and getting numerical of elevation over
the whole complex plane was yet another
sort of big thing
then very quickly i think people here
just before my time people realize you
need a few properties like derivative
and and a little bit later an asymptotic
series
but over time we've accumulated many
more properties
and ultimately what this gives us is a
way to think about functions as function
classes
because what we can't have for instance
this is useful in its own right
so for instance students and others want
to find out if a function is injective
there's a lot of wolfram alpha traffic
for that but also for solvers
the way you write solvers is to you
often need to check
a certain property in which case you can
use a whole
bank of theorem a whole network of
theorems are true for that
class of functions and now you can have
algorithms that go that way
now these things do that for you
instead of you trying to ad hoc do that
and they do it
efficiently um and some of them is
extremely efficient
um and so this is a this is a way to get
to function classes and function
properties
and uh if we go there there's a guide
page for it
it's easy to click from uh there's one
thing here that you're gonna
get hung up on right away which is the c
at the end
and the thing is that we can't have q at
the end because q functions are liars
in my book q functions has to return
true or false
but often you have parameters there and
you can return a boolean statement
that when those parameters gets
instantiated can become true or false
but you know just returning true or
false for something that depends on a
parameter
is always a lie well often a lie
okay i think we'd be better off calling
it test injective function test or
something
then see but then you know so we're
going to introduce this
you know i wish we'd had it 10 years ago
this convention because right now we
we've done
um like no ending for a lot of functions
um that that does this
um but i don't know that we want test
because test has many meanings
hypothesis test
for instance this convention isn't going
to make it but but
we can come up with something okay okay
let's go
um this is going to be a long and
complicated review
possibly i mean it's not i mean these
are slightly sophisticated but but i
also expect us to do more than one hour
okay
this gives you the overview and you sort
of see what you think is
complicated or what needs more time and
stuff
what is this what is this function
properties
yeah this name at a guide page
am i going to be able to get to these
functions from here yeah
i just didn't make them it doesn't look
like it no i mean i just didn't make
them hyperlinks but just
mark that and then go to the docky tools
and click on that
that dot and you can go directly to it
that dot thing this thing here yeah
was it selected
now this is not new and we already have
yes
but it should be on this page zero i'm
saying it's a function problem
okay so our support for special
functions is significantly deeper
than just numerical evaluation in fact
numerical evaluation
alone makes them close to useless from a
symbolic point of view
so how far can injective function get
what do you mean by that well i mean if
i give it a complicated thing here i see
it can get pretty far i mean the whole
point here this is not some like table
lookup for special functions
does this work with discrete functions
as well
well um
depends on how you define discrete
functions
functions over the integers that's not
going to work for this guy
no why why
sorry i said why because it's not
implemented
okay but it's conceptually can work
conceptually it could work yes
but the two domains that are supported
are reals and complexes
well it's an interesting piece of
functionality for sure
um
this particular one you know apart from
us having those
to-do lists wrong that font for that if
it's just wrong
we've been through this several times
before
that's the type setting for conditional
expression so
i know it's wrong
yes okay did you just take that
vendor as a bug report for conditional
expression
yes i did okay i mean this is like the
third time i pointed out the same thing
okay in any case
all right
and i think the applications are getting
in place i think these applications is
where you learn
why you care you don't learn why you
care
so much in the notes or in the scope
i think this should be called function
injectivity
function continuity function analyticity
admit i don't know what the noun for
neuromorphic is
never heard that i don't know why but i
think
so function injectivity would return
true false typically
or they can you know
conditional answer
test is the wrong name for this
yeah i mean i kind of like going with
function domain
function range function injectivity
function sign function convexity
seems to make sense to me those are a
little bit different
those three there sign monotonicity
convexity so we have this problem
they're basically four functions that
you want for sine you want to know so we
have
we have four functions for numbers so we
have positive
non-negative negative non-positive so we
have four of them
so in principle there are four of those
for functions too
same thing go with monotonicity you have
increasing decreasing
strictly increasing strictly decreasing
yes and you have four for convexity as
well
so these ones return well what about
multivariate convexity
multivariate any of these well the
monotonicity is not defined but
they um why
because one variable sorry
it's defined for any particular variable
yeah for one variable then it's not
multivariate no i understand but
multivariate function
well okay all right
okay but the other two work
multivariates
okay so you've got an option here how
does that relate to intervals
so if you if you support that here
you've got to support that for intervals
no sense i don't have to why why do you
say that
because the same question no it's not
the same
issue intervals are made for interval
computation
meaning you know for i know that you've
had this debate
elsewhere how are we going to kind of
represent open closed
type intervals
but this doesn't necessitate solving
your interval problem
here because we're solving it here no i
understand that but you need something
which is going to
be usable elsewhere
um why because we don't want to have two
concepts here
that's interesting ic points out that
there is a
a resource function in wfr called
function objectivity
have you guys looked at that no why not
not i don't know we wrote this several
years ago
so um that was probably long before it
existed so no we have not looked at that
okay let me go and look at it sure
oh it came from the wolfman alpha math
team
well this was a request from the wolfram
alpha team to do this
um in injectives rejected by objective
okay and i think they put it in here as
a placeholder for
wayne okay
okay but i kind of agree that having the
explicit
complete names is better
rather than putting it all in one
function oh
sandra is immediately asking on a
livestream what's that c thing the c
thing isn't making it conditional means
conditional
but it isn't going to make it so yeah i
think it's a convention we should have
across the system
not only here but across the system
yeah but i don't think we're going to be
able to do that i mean i i think that
this is a
you know it's a nice thing to say but
i mean i think function subjectivity no
that's that
avoids it in a different way so that
solves it
but it won't solve this problem will
come up repeatedly it has come up
many times independently i understand i
understand i understand the issue is
things which accuse but not cues and how
strictly do we do we we cannot use q
we cannot use q q is a liar function
it works great for structural things it
works terrible for
things with parameters and conditions
i don't think you should say that so
quickly i think there's a
it's one of these things where i think
we should look at what q
functions exist when we've done this
which i know we have done even though we
shouldn't have done it
of having them not be definitive true or
false
i think we should separately somebody
should look at all q functions and try
and figure this out
and see whether there's a nice
way
to generalize this okay i don't know
what it is right now
but a general way to generalize it so to
speak
um okay so which functions here
so the okay so what we're looking here
it is monotonicity
so this is a right so function
monotonicity
would go along function subjectivity
it's just true false or a condition
right yeah that's what i was saying that
those guys behave a little different
because they effectively return
what's like a sign basically you know
this three value
logic or four valued which do the the
monotonicity and so on yeah yeah these
guys
because you can have you know it can be
positive negative
or both i'm sorry sorry non-positive
non-negative or both
yes i understand
i kind of agree with this i think that's
a reasonable thing to do and it agrees
with how the
s-i-g-n function works for numbers
right it's going to do the same thing if
it's a constant function it'll it'll
give the same result as some
the sine function on the number right
okay but now
okay i don't really like the name
strictness i think we need to understand
what it's going to be elsewhere
so that we can at least reuse that name
elsewhere sure no i'm
i'm i'm not super fond of it either i
was trying
i was trying to come up with other names
for it all right okay so we'll come back
to that in a minute
nick on our live stream suggest generate
conditions for queue functions
i think that's a separate uh who is who
is making
notes here that's a separate meeting
that we need about
yes i'm making them yes okay fine
all right it's not always going to be
yeah i don't okay it's not always going
to be conditional it's sometimes
before the on our live stream is
suggesting the um
uh a curried form but i don't think it's
a good idea
i don't think it's sensible i think this
concept of subjectivity and so on are so
um yeah i mean
i mean look it's elementary i mean it
comes up super early
uh right so let's say function sine
of a times e to the x with respect to x
right is that what i'm saying
okay beautiful except for the type
setting
which drives me crazy
right um
okay
all right so down here these are
function continuous function analytic
function i think we should just say
function metamorphic
oh no no that would be function
continuity
right defender are you taking notes for
the new names or
yes yes i am thanks
i don't know what the right function
i don't know what the now what the noun
for paramorphic is
i think it's metamorphicity like your
holomorphicity say your metamorphicity
i think okay a little bit weird
it's not terrible actually it's really
not terrible okay
so
are you telling me things about okay so
let's say i say
your function convexity
but so now if i say function convexity
um x how do i give a condition uh
sine x comma condition
sine x in a brace like this yeah common
condition
it's concave no that's right i'm just
thinking about the
but but now
why is this saying indeterminate because
it can be all anything
as opposed to it being what if it could
be
there is a any linear function
is both convex and concave so that
returns zero
if it's both okay if it's neither
it's indeterminate it's neither convex
nor concave
which is true for sine it's it's not
sine in general so basically this is the
sine of the second derivative basically
yeah if it has a derivative
yeah okay
so i see so this is the sine of the
function itself the sine of its first
derivative of the sine of its second
derivative
right and first approximation yep
it's reasonable enough
and they're strongly connected if you
integrate
a positive function you get a strictly
increasing function
yes indeed if you integrate a strictly
increasing function you get a strictly
convex function
no good
um but it works in general i mean that
that hierarchy
is a is a good hierarchy okay so the
issue here
is
strictness strict condition
see the question is there are two kinds
of things that could be strict
um there's a question here about
that's a good question from sandra um
why is this only giving this case and
says kind of you're out of luck for the
other case
i guess that's what we do in general we
give a condition
we don't give all the different cases
unless you ask for them right
yeah how can i ask for them in this case
i don't know if you can ask for them and
it's not true that you can
in general our algorithms in general
never give you the option to return all
there is a few
exceptions in integrate where we give
all but that also has exponential blow
up of cases happening of course
nice enough okay i'm still trying to
understand the strictness so the issue
is
the condition that you are implying
you know the monotonicity condition is
what's strict
it's not that you're interpreting the
input in a strict way it is that the
condition being applied is a strict
condition
yeah they're all given as inequalities
and equate and those can turn into
strict inequalities
and they're usually used also like you
say
is this strictly positive or just
positive and i understand okay
is this strictly increasing or just
increasing is this strictly convex or
just convex
strict enforcement of condition
that's really weird
um
for these askings this analogous to find
instance what is the
analogy with find instance here
by the way could you report i don't know
why is fine instance
giving completely stupid search results
here
um devendra those are two bugs to report
that that does this did can you report
that bug
did you understand devendra
i'm taking notes as well i've got it
i'll tell devyn the search team about it
okay the other thing is um
when i was in this state here what
happened to devendra defender is
i'm here i'm here sorry i just moved for
a minute yeah um
uh okay in any case all right so we got
a name there that we got to deal with
is what um
oh my gosh i'm sorry another bug not
fixed here
is that this raft is disappearing
immediately
do you see that
who is the one taking notes is it yes
okay
do you understand this is the same same
front-end bug that we've seen for like
three weeks
okay yes
you call that cell a raft now i call the
attached cell a raft
is it your name or is it a is that a
general name
no i made it up okay okay it's a partly
silly name but it's a name that we
know the team understands okay it's a
floating raft
okay okay that is also used for for help
you know um
okay uh
it's it's like using the strict
definition of the property
um
yes okay but i never got what the
what the person thought that how it
relates to fine instance it's oh because
because the point is that the point is
that
that you're not finding all so you're
fine not finding all conditions you're
simply finding
an example of an answer without okay so
in that sense it's not quite
instance fine truly an instance this
finds
a generic tried to be generic but the
gener generosity
might be only half of the complex plane
or something
that's right but it's not a set of
measures zero in the complex plane
and it's no it's not like finding
instances it truly finds something a
measure zero
it finds a point an instance
right okay anyway so we we've got one
issue here is with the
strictness name but i think in terms of
now
i want to look at okay so convexity i
like this plus minus
i think you should say in this
documentation here convex plus one
concave minus one or whatever it is just
put it right in yes
convex plus one concave minus one
you know increasing last one
decreasing minus one type thing
it's really simple or
we could just put convex colon plus one
concave colon minus one
comma dot dot
um
okay there's a question from sander here
on what does
something do
so this isn't this is not a new function
so um what's the ques i don't know what
the question is well the question is
what is that
the reason that says zero is the
function
is not periodic with any non-zero period
right that's right
because eventually this function will be
i mean it's a non-commensurate thingy
dinghy
yes oh my gosh this bug is driving me
crazy
beautiful okay all right now
any of these things they just return
true false right
function continuity functionality and so
on
right with possible conditions right yep
okay so the only issue so do they have
any weird options
no double check but i'm pretty sure they
don't
it only came up with those guys yeah
nothing weird
just standard stuff
look i would say of these things
so i'm just saying why is the period
infinity why is it zero not infinity
yeah you can argue that
and people have argued that and come
both to both conclusions
yeah i can see that all right but but so
this also works better with complex
periods because we can very much have
complex periods
and what does infinity mean in that case
how do we get a complex period here
will that work yeah but you need to take
something with an actual complex period
like
you know like some elliptic function or
something
jacobi's it could be a senior probably
yeah i know
how many arguments does jacoby have i
can never remember
choose x comma k and the case could have
add metal numeric
x probably
nice nice but now
i don't understand why that's coming out
as a list as opposed to a complex number
it it has two periods
but isn't it aren't its two periods just
in the real and complex really imaginary
directions
no
i mean we the ones that we give here yes
i'm confused so if i make this pi over 3
plus
i for example oh i see
so when we when you give
a complex when you say it's over the
complexes what you get back is a list
is it always a pair
yes but you also have multivariate which
returns
you know a list you know so this
this works just fine for multivariate
you know n variables too
so does function convexity work for for
multivariate also
yes so if i say function convexity
and that's actually where we need it
because we use this in our convex
optimization
to classify and transform okay why does
it say that
because it's not convex but it's a
saddle
so it's not convex
yeah i see but so i see
i see but but but so is there not a
characterization of the saddle
that is useful i mean in other words
a generalization of convexity for this
case
what i mean what kind of generalization
i don't know i don't know i mean isn't
that wasn't that what all these
hessian-y things
uh are telling you is well this one just
tells that that it i mean if you look at
the hessian of this
you will see that it's in-depth
it's an in the term it's in indefinite
form it's not
positive or negative definite okay
okay well i'm not sure i know what i'm
talking about but it's like the
principal components somehow yeah but
you're going to see that it has
one positive eigenvalue and one negative
no i understand that but but to be able
to say
in a sense what are the eigenvalues
rather than just oh is it convex
altogether or not
are they all do they all agree or oh
i've got
two positive eigenvalues and three
negative eigenvalues for instance
wouldn't that not be a useful thing too
that's a different function though
that's not convenient no
okay fair enough okay does it have a
name
i mean this is this is what you look at
these catastrophe analysis and stuff i
mean this
yeah that's where you
but that's not going in this direction
fair enough okay
all right let's go on looking at these
here okay so we've got
condition strictness i'm not sure i'm
totally like that name
but it's better than just strictness in
my view i was looking for something a
little bit less generic
like that and that's not fantastic but i
think
let's go with that for the time being
but i think we want to talk about it
again
these two are amazing functions so what
they will do
is they will tell you yeah
we've had them i wrote versions of this
long time ago
but we've now made them production um
and so we've used them inside so for
instance when you plot the function and
it can
figure out where the discontinuities are
or the singularities are
that's what's being used under the hood
so these are really giving conditions
like reduce
yes
and they can be fairly complicated
well you have one example right there
that's fairly complicated at the end
yeah i understand i'm just concerned
about the names the name
function singularities because it
suggests that boom boom boom it's just
values
could be its own function oh but you
know function singularities can be
curves when you multivariate you can
have
singularity surfaces singularity curves
absolutely no i realize that but
i see so you think the singularities
and that's that's something we found
that the theories
i mean i wish the theory is farther
ahead here but we really need it
for convergence and all kinds of other
problems so if i want to take this thing
and i want to just
get numbers out of it for the univariate
case if it is
if it has numbers i mean it could have i
mean what happens if the
um we'll take something simple i click
gamma okay well there you have 10 is
something simple there okay
no i'm going to take i'm going to take
one of the more complicated cases i'm
going to take
and take sine 1 over x
okay and now how do i know that that's
an essential singularity
that's further analysis that's in the
serious expansion
you have to do further analysis to clear
classify it
i understand that but what i'm asking is
is is there a function that tells me
that
no there's no shrink wrap
function that tells you that at this
point
what are we going to call it if we have
it function singularity analysis
um i don't know i mean because what it
would naturally return is an association
saying sanctuary singularities are oblah
that's poles
that make sense
i don't know i think it's those concepts
seem to to
degenerate in the multivariate case they
don't seem to work anymore they
certainly do
right so i
well maybe that's just a wfr level
function
um okay what we've discussed
which we can't do now um
so this function is super fast you know
for in a fairly complex expression it
will actually return in
microseconds not milliseconds
microseconds
which function this one function
singularities
it's amazing
what i'm looking at polynomial q i'm on
to the next item
oh my god what is this
what is polynomial expression q
yeah i wanted to have a longer
discussion sort of
so this is a a the problem
adam needs to be here in this discussion
for it to kind of make a lot of sense
i don't okay all right fine but let's
put it on a different agenda then
yeah let's let's do that and he's on
vacation unfortunately now so it's
okay but roughly this is some happy
hackery to fix up another piece of
hackery
yeah well we should fix it some other
way
well that was going down okay that's why
i said revisit
okay oh i see it okay fine all right is
that is that it for the discussion of
those things here
it is yeah
therefore chandra is asking for an n
function singularities for the real
points rather than the equalities
yeah i'm i guess i'm asking the question
if i get out
something like this you have to i want
for it yeah but how do i get
how do i solve how do i just get a list
of numbers
within a certain range if i say
take this solve it within that range
okay
and solve percent 18 now what
whether you have to give the range of
which you want it
okay so i'm saying percent 18 comma
0 less than x less than 20.
for instance except it's oh it has none
there so
that was a shortlist that's the gamma
function yeah sorry
oh god this bug is driving me crazy for
that
okay and i can say and solve values here
no why not it doesn't exist
yeah i've never heard of that we should
have it and do the obvious thing
i mean we have that for diesel values
right we do
yes we do this should exist
for the exact same purpose
right it was worse for diesel because
there you you
if i try to i understand but i don't i
don't i'm not arguing with you i
i kind of tend to think it should exist
too let's try and make it
so values and and solve values
okay
okay so basically what you say is
n soul values function singularities
blah blah blah
and if this thing is bounded so if i say
here
the gamma function
minus 20
what what what what what what it doesn't
take a condition i think
it should well it will just spit it back
out again
i know it will which is kind of okay
i guess for workflows yeah i think it's
a very good thing for it to do i don't
think it should complain i think it's
just come back right
right back out again but i mean it could
be
it won't be exactly the same it'll be an
ended thing
right yeah it will should work
okay let us keep going
jacoby epsilon i have never heard of
that
jacoby zn we are getting exotic here
this is a big this is all triggered by a
bunch of bug reports
on our elliptic functions several of
them from you
or some of them from you not directly
from me surely
no maybe not you might be right okay
yes most likely
this should all be you know 100 percent
cleaned
but that meant a complete
re-implementation of our those elliptic
functions
wow elliptic kef pi
and as a side benefit it also got
updated in improvements to all these
jacobi
functions okay
and what was i going to say
well my functions are they part of the
same i mean those are slightly different
it's different that's related to hoin
okay so there's a
that came out of you know since we're
now world experts on hoin
literally yes lemay
is just one transformation away from
hoin that's why
we were able to get lame now it was very
efficient to do them now
have we not had them at all before no
we've had spheroidal harmonics which is
sort of yes yes yes yes yes no i
remember lame functions you know in a
bronwitz and stegen
they're in an obscure part at the back
of the book right
so are we done with the branson's taken
now is this it is this we're
just compiling a dlmf benchmark
now um to see
where we are at with respect to that
just to
to and then we should just check about
instance taken i mean i i
no we should we we're doing some 10
different sources to see where we're at
now with special functions generally
speaking
it's only been 30 years we're finally
there yeah but we're actually measuring
it now steve we're sort of checking and
measuring and
actually the one other thing that they
have and ronson's taken if i remember
correctly and it's been
rather a long time since i actually
looked at it but they have some tables
for numerical analysis
in the back you know weights for
gaussian quadrature and things like that
which i think
if we don't have those in the function
repository we should put them there i
mean i don't think that
i really don't think anybody needs
weights for gaussian quadrature as
primary things because they are
you know just inside the algorithm right
but we probably should expose that in
the function repository can we
um devendra could you make sure that yes
maybe mark
could uh i mean i know marcus has
developed functions
internal functions that do that but
nowadays we can put them in the function
repository and document them
okay yeah um
actually that q park hammer was another
gospelism
um right i know he's been a couple
hammer enthusiast for
he's been hammering on that function for
years you know we hired him to try to
have him implement it
which failed yes i know okay that was a
little
time ago but now he's working on the
outside and finding problems
which is fine we you know things have
progressed weird
yes um
interesting so so there's a question
from nick here
reduce wow that's that's going to be a
challenging thing
if we say here let me show you this one
that's going to be challenging
interesting but challenging
yeah so but he's on to something so we
are gradually getting
into sort of a kind of a type system
but not really but i mean it is it so
one thing that we are introducing
for sure is matrix classes more
substantially
because they're needed in optimization
modeling but we will need these function
classes
eventually the symmetric matrix type
thing and so on i mean this
is this is in a sense the lie of type
systems
i mean really what you want are
conditions on things and type systems
are a pretend way of giving conditions
that is that yes yes but they're also
sort of a very
type i mean they don't need to be called
type systems just because they work on a
structural
at the structural level um
no i understand but the point is that
with types well i mean the
calculus of types so to speak right the
question is is this a type
and the answer is meh who knows it
depends on who's
defining it i'm looking at many kind
types is a broad you know the things
that been used by compiler writers
and language designers is sort of one
slice of types it's not the full slice
there are lots of use in statistics um
and and even more using their improvers
but
but but they're different slices to the
whole thing by the way
roger i don't know if you've been paying
attention to it but but i've been doing
as part of this meta mathematics theory
of meta mathematics project i have been
understanding in fact
we should have this conversation the the
um you know we've really been exposing
uh things like lean the theorem
uh you know the theorem inventory they
have about 30 000 theorems in them
and we've been kind of ingesting those
and at least understanding
at a infrastructural level how all these
theorems work
but i think it'd be very interesting to
understand
you know uh how we make use of those
you know all those theorems and
i mean but here is the thing okay i mean
here's a very practical thing
related to that yeah which is that
the thing is that when you say that a
function is monotone
there is basically a web a network of
theorems that are now true
i'm saying it's like a key
now you can use this result and that
result
right well i'm sorry what were you
saying for for which
just pick any one of these properties
that we had let's say that you say it's
a monotone function
you know that for monotone functions
they can be
um they can be um they can be a
a skill just measure for instance they
have finite
the bounded variation they have there's
a whole slew of results that come out
as a result of knowing that key which
i'm saying
yes and that's what's good about that's
how mathematics sort of aggregated and
and
well i mean but if we look at for
instance i mean let's see if i can pull
one up
um
let's see
i mean this is this is metamath which is
one of the more
one of the ones that is not considered
as modern as it might be
um that's uh
that's lean
so i mean if we take for example
functional analysis wherever it is
hmm i don't see functional analysis
let's see what should i look at here um
analysis maybe okay so analytic
interesting so i mean we have we
we are in fact using a bunch of these
closure properties now to get efficient
computation of these properties
well i mean we have this lean link
thing which has been built to this
i don't know if you've been paying
attention yeah i mean i don't think this
would be of any use to us for these
functions per se
but i'm just saying that we are using
closure results of this nature
to get that's why it doesn't just work
on special individual special functions
would this not be useful to us
why would why would none of the stuff be
useful
i mean it's useful to browse to know the
results but
calling lean and these are things that
work in microseconds what we're talking
about
just setting up the call to lean would
be a millisecond thing at least i'm sure
well i i understand but
in independent of efficiency the
question is this whole
structure here of theorems right
yeah it might be super interesting but i
don't think we would call on it
no i understand that but the question is
whether for example
whether one can basically machine
generate code
that is that is provable from these
theorems for instance
right that i'm pretty sure one can
that will be interesting yeah ethan is
suggesting fine theorem and theorem
search
yes yes we are well aware of this issue
this issue
is a huge kind of worms because
the reason we want this you know i'm
just saying to it to sort of where
it goes away from special to general
functions think about our solvers we
have maybe on the order of 100
solvers in calculus and algebra and
they're pretty heavy
beasts each and every one of them we
have on the order of 300 special
functions
should each one of these solvers know
about each and every special function
right that's 30 000 cases just there
right no not scalable not doable yeah
right
no i understand that you have to bucket
them yes and that's
and their buckets are called function
classes
yes see this is an interesting thing for
the general sort of theory of
abstraction in mathematics that's an
interesting thing
because you get you take 30 cases right
and then which buckets do you make
exactly
and they're clearly history dependent i
mean there might be real
essential things but the question is
like who works on things and that you
know
right okay
let me just um
i we really should talk by the way roger
because this is an active subject right
now
for these um because we're generalizing
axiomatic theory
to be able to ingest all kinds of stuff
and so it is you know this is our moment
for figuring out
how we take formalized mathematics and
connect it to all these other things
right um
so the next group polynomic functions is
an old function we introduced it
in version 7.
what we're doing now is consumerizing it
did i more you yeah we're consumerizing
it more
so it has it's going to have nice type
setting unfortunately that's not
and i saw changes already this morning
from italian okay hey listen with
respect to typesetting could we do a
review that includes the
the typesetting of those conditional uh
results
that you have i think if we have ite in
that discussion
it our life would be so much easier
because that's where it all goes
all right fine okay we have a ti and we
need somebody from design
in there yeah okay and the other thing
is that differential route
which sort of covers 70 to 80 percent of
a special functions
is now behaving like a true special
function in that
it has continuity based numerical
evaluations
i'm sorry continuation based right
and so guaranteed precision behavior
and things like that
and and that's in preparation for being
able to
uh output these functions massively for
lots of different solvers
to extend their capabilities
okay we we are about to need to go to
our next meeting but
let's just um uh have a quick
preview here what is cylindrical formula
it's an
optimized this it's going to take a
little bit more discussion but it's
basically an
optimized cylindrical decomposition that
preserves enough structure
that it can be manipulated afterwards so
it's
it leads to a cylindrical algebraic
decomposition
whatever we're calling it cylindrical
decomposition what does it return right
now
it returns a logical a boolean formula
like the normal over there yes so
i see so this is a an unevaluated form
of a cylindrical decomposition
right and it's evaluated to a stage okay
but that stage maintains enough
properties that you can for instance
boolean combine these
things afterward very efficiently so how
does it relate to regions
actually we came up with this during
regions
but it's not an explicit and it's used
inside
some region computations but isn't it in
fact a region
you could say it's it's it's a it's a
optimized form for a subclass of the
implicit regions
yes okay all right but i mean in
principle i could just take
one of these cylindrical decompositions
or cylindrical formulas
and i could just make a picture of it
couldn't i with graphics or something
yes if it's low enough dimension yes
obviously
okay
what got done um i mean that okay so
this is this hooking up
all the things no so those two deuce two
okay that was a little bit too
aspirational
it's going to it's gonna probably make
it till next release unfortunately
this is you here i am well we just we
need a new generalized multivariate form
of root objects to do it
and we're not going to be able to pull
that off oh i see this is maximize not
and maximize
right wow but it means that we this is
this is
in my book amazing what we'll be able to
do and i just don't want to talk
about super much yet okay
um
what got done what what's new in the
laplace transform world
right there for the inverse particularly
we have the bromwich counter integral
method and numerical inversion
as part of the new inverse laplace
transform
so how could you do an inverse laplace
transform without a
a branch contour uh well you can do so
rational case because
all partial fractions and you can do it
for some other case by table lookup
convolution
shifting etc but that's a small bunch of
techniques compared to
so basically if you have an infinite
number of poles you could do nothing in
12 point and now you can do lots in 12.2
how do we represent console integrals in
general
we don't i mean i actually integrate has
a you can give an explicit path
but we we're working on prototypes to
provide
a contour a more practically usable
contour
integrate like named contours yes
yes and and so here are some things and
i might get good feedback on the stream
here
so often when you do contour integrate
you might integrate let's say a
meromorphic function
so the only kinds of singularities are
poles or something right
and all you care about is the routing of
the contour around the poles
yes so you don't want it super exact you
just want to sort of include exclude
certain things
so you might have an overall contour but
you want to include and exclude
points or maybe even curves if they're
discontinuity
like branch cut curves um right so
what's our analogy to this i mean so
basically this is this
is life with sort of topological or
homotopic
you know sort of except what i was
saying now
is only relevant when you're in the
analytic or meromorphic case
if you if you work on general complex
functions you actually need the exact
contour it's not defined at all
what you do you know you you're
integrating i understand
i understand but but what what you're
saying is there's a homotopic
equivalence class
of you know of contours
that we would like to be able to
characterize they will all give the same
results right
which we'd like to characterize more
roughly what you want to give an easier
specification language for the user
right but isn't this analogous to the
inside outside conditions for pdes and
so on
in other words what you're saying is in
a pde you say
i want this boundary value these
boundary values inside this region
outside this region whatever
isn't that an analogous somewhat
analogous case to the thing i want
you know i've got this random set of
poles in the complex plane
i want to route this contour you know
what do i want to
say i want to route this contour
basically what you need to say is which
poles are inside which poles are outside
yes yes that's basically what you want
to say
and what about that's what i that's what
i would yeah but that's what i was
saying you want to include
poles inside or exclude the outside
and you want to do the same for for cuts
you know curves
you want to include a curve or exclude a
curve often you want to exclude a curve
if it's a discontinuity
although i guess what what happens is
that there will be implications
if you have routed a contour that isn't
a crazy contour
and you've excluded certain polls then
polls to the right of that left of that
whatever it is
will be automatically excluded that's
the case that would be
yes in fact we use it for numerical
inversion as well we try and
include all the poles by taking a large
enough contour which
covers them at least enough to get the
numerical value right
so that's the numerical laplace
transform so what the numerical inverse
laplace transform so that's the contour
integral
but if you're doing purely numerically
then what you want to do is kind of take
a
contour which is large enough so to
speak that
and and then you get a very nice
approximation so people work with these
fixed contours
but thanks to all the singularity
functions we can now do it much better
in 12.2 so you're already reusing adam
stuff inside this
numerical version quite heavily
the numerical evaluation of these
integral transforms is a heavily
requested feature and that's probably
function repository items yes it's the
thing that people want
so badly um the laplace transform is
easily the most used integral transform
um that we have again uh
a lot of requests for upgrades
improvements so this is kind of
it's both a refactoring which makes it
modular and easily extendable for the
future
as well as new methods like this
braunwich method so is this is there an
n laplace transform i don't remember no
so the way we've done it right now
there isn't the way we've done it right
now is that if you give a numerical
argument
to it it uses the numerical methods i
see
okay i think if you want an n inverse
laplace transform what people often
write
that you get it at a single point but i
think
i think that that if we're going to do
an
n if we're going to do n versions of all
our integral transforms there's a lot of
them
in summation transforms then i think you
want the full
function not just a point
right i'm coming back to this homotopic
business because i think it's quite
complicated i mean isn't this what
you know all these monotony groups and
all this kind of stuff is for
characterizing
when you know
you know what i'm talking about the the
yes yes
i mean i mean all of that is
is in a way to deal with
contour integration cycles that you're
going to integrate along cycles of
various kinds
i just wonder what structure we're going
to need to build to represent that stuff
in a reasonable way because i mean in a
sense
wow but it has to be a usable language
too i mean a user
because people come but what i've
noticed is that people
a certain kind of people that think that
there is nothing except for analytic
functions
and polls in the world there seem to be
a lot of
they think that that's it that's not it
if you're going to do a numerical
version of that then it integrates it
needs a definite contour
if you give it something non-analytic
which we
we are fully capable of working with now
at least numerically and visually our
complex plot makes it easy to understand
and start to study these non-analytic
non-meromorphic creatureoids
right um
so
okay all right so look it sounds like
we're going to need
some follow-up on this but it'll be
fairly brief
uh a few additional things here um but
this is
uh and we do need to talk about that
cylindrical
function thing but it sounds like that
needs adam and so on
right okay looks like we are
um uh good to go here
and we have another meeting that you're
probably in roger about visualization
which we will also be live streaming
in a couple of minutes yep
so see